in the central highlands of Mexico howdy
is building the world's highest car
plant in San Jose Java an hour's drive
from the city of Puebla vehicles will be
assembled some 2400 meters above sea
level starting in 2016 a staff of 3,800
will produce the new generation of the
q5 crossover SUV finding enough skilled
workers is a challenge dai mexico
germany's Minister of State in the
Foreign Office says there's no history
of German style apprenticeship programs
in Mexico so she told her Mexican
partners that they need to create the
necessary structures step by step she
says they'll help the Mexicans every
step of the way if they want to
implement such training programs within
Mexican and state fish that says itís
team 20 gets tossed to isla hospital
system here in Mexico Falcon Road but
howdy isn't prepared to wait for changes
to Mexico's education system in
cooperation with several partners the
automaker has set up its own training
center near the plant
you
jeez no Thomas Ziggy says howdy aims to
have the same quality standards
worldwide so investing in the
qualifications of its workers is key
here outtie is working together with
Puebla zoology the state of Puebla and
its own trainers to train the 3800 new
county workers who produce the q5 year
the center of specialization was
inaugurated here in a festive ceremony
over 1500 workers should receive
additional qualifications here each year
at present around 170 young people are
taking part in an apprenticeship program
here and future some 80 youths are
expected to participate yearly we're
very happy to have out here in in Puebla
because we know that Puebla is a perfect
place for Audi to be here but we're
going to have the benefits of at this
big big company they are company that
put a lot of effort in the people who
work in the company starting in 2016
Audi plans to produce 150,000 q5 s a
year in San Jose Chiappa destined for
sale worldwide as part of Audis vision
to become a truly global player in the
luxury car segment via visions Howdy's
uber Volkl says their aim is to make
premium cars here and that to enable
this they've set up a very intensive
training program 580 workers from Mexico
are currently being schooled in
processes at outies plant in Ingolstadt
and neck Arzu they're being trained so
that when howdy starts building cars
here the automaker will have experienced
workers right from the start who train
youth we attend zodavia here is out of
bound beginning does really business for
our Setsubun hardened media for Namita
vatican's protester stratton fabio lima
Tina's is among the first workers being
prepared for her new tasks that also
includes learning to overcome language
barriers
I had then so by intensive course
Fabiola says she took part in a super
intensive German course and then spent
eight months in Germany that's how she
learned German she says it's a big help
as lots of Germans work here so it
facilitates communication if you can
speak German can do is straighten their
lichte is he mom for she didn't but she
admits it can be hard to understand
everything the Germans say if they
talked too quickly or in dialect first
and Alice over 70,000 people have
applied for the new plants thirty-eight
hundred jobs showing the attractiveness
OD as an employer and San Jose Chiappa
as a production location and Audi is
ensuring that its reputation for
producing quality German made cars will
extend to the q5 even if it's made in
Mexico
you